[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
let's bring in
tom e curran the patriots insider
working for
nbc sports boston uh wow you've you
gotta what kind of shirt you got on
there today
well i i uh i haven't yet gone to your
website to pick up
the the spare inventory so i have a nice
it's a i thought
fritzy said it's loud golf shirt friday
yeah and apparently i've been duped
i've todd did you tell tom it's not loud
guys
i might let him down a dark path and now
we can all like
kind of humiliate him and laugh at him
you got catfish by fritzy
not the first no well we're glad to have
you tom
i don't know how new england reacted to
peter schrager's
uh mock draft yesterday peter of course
works for uh the nfl network
and he raised some eyebrows saying the
patriots he had them moving up to number
four
to take perhaps a quarterback justin
fields
unpatriot like what did you make of that
yeah it's unpatriotic and i don't think
that's gonna happen when you look at the
amount that san francisco
had to pay to get up to number three
patriots are not going to be in the
business of giving the 15th and then
probably two more first rounders to go
up there
and get a guy who i thought mike
lombardi was was really good on his
podcast this week explaining why the
grades just won't justify it on a justin
fields or a trey lance if those guys are
the two remaining
you can't just jump up there and then
not have the verbiage as
lombardi explained it to say okay he
grades at this level to be that level
pick
he's going to be one of the top 10
players in the league he makes everyone
around him better he
requires more than one player to to
defend him and take him away i just
don't know the
ramps and fields are going to be those
guys how involved is
i guess belichick getting does he ever
get impatient
you know that he's kind of seeing
everybody you know hey guys are getting
their quarterbacks i don't really have
my quarterback we spent a lot of money
on free agents but we still don't have
a rock solid quarterback is bill getting
more impatient as he gets older
i don't think so i mean he's been
paralyzed since 2017 at the position
they traded jimmy garoppolo away and now
all they've done is kind of chase tom
brady out of town
draft danny uplink draft jared stidham
signed cam newton trade for brian hoyer
i mean if he's impatient he hasn't
signaled it yet and
really i think belichick is more
hardwired on the draft
to kind of scoff at the rest of the
league when it gets thirsty
and try and be that
guy who likes to buy distressed assets
so
you know sitting at 15 i could see him
jumping down dan but
you can do that when you have tom brady
but when you don't have tom brady
then you can make moves but it still
comes back to
boy imagine if they had a really good
quarterback i think that there however
is some well-founded
confidence bordering on arrogance of
look we had a bad roster last year we
won seven games with cam he didn't have
an off season
we had actual tight ends and wide
receivers
that the patriots really and bill i
don't think really blames himself for
not staffing the rooms but he ought to
but we add all those players we get a
bunch back on defense and we're better
there you think we're not going to win
11 games you're out of your mind we can
put anybody back there
and that to me is is an interesting
aspect of the patriots look yeah maybe
we might have
a duct tape answer a quarterback right
now
but we're good enough on sundays and at
other positions
to mitigate that issue that we
absolutely do have
if a quarterback is there what are the
patriots 15th
if if a quarterback is there somehow do
you think bill takes a quarterback
if he's just sitting there if trey lance
is just sitting there
it's got to be hard it's got to be hard
i mean when you think of all the players
that the patriots have passed on in in
the first rounds
and later in rounds second round picks
you know lamar jackson was sitting there
at 31 they took sony michelle i
understand
why the patriots might look at lamar
jackson and say look he's got one
indefensible skill in terms of his speed
and his electricity as a runner but we
don't know how he projects and
well lamar jackson's been an mvp sony
michelle is now going to be a backup
running back to damien harris so
i i think that they probably would pass
and take a better player who's been
pushed down the board by all those
quarterbacks and wide receivers
that's what i think they would do but i
don't know if that's the right thing to
do
and then i wonder with the niners going
all in on whoever they're gonna take at
number three then you got jimmy
garoppolo
there as you know in a a lame duck
season here
yeah does does bill is there part of him
that says
i don't need to move up in the draft i'm
eventually going to be trading for jimmy
garoppolo
yeah i think that he has very much let
the game come to him
at the quarterback position i think that
is really what they are because if you
look at jimmy garoppolo or teddy
bridgewater those guys to me are
interchangeable
yet bridgewater is actually more durable
despite the catastrophic luggage
he had and he's eight million dollars a
year cheaper
so if you trade for teddy bridgewater
which i don't think is going to happen
in 17 million and i don't think the
patriots are going to trade for
garoppolo at 25 but i don't think iraq
was going to take a pay cut
so they're pinched in i dan
i would say it's 65 to 75 percent likely
you're going to see
either cam newton or jared stidham under
center when the season begins they will
add someone
but i don't know if it's going to be
anybody we say oh that guy's definitely
better than stinnerman newton
we're talking to tom curran the patriots
insider julian edelman
the uh knee situation um may not be able
to play this upcoming season which
might mark the end of julian edelman's
career here uh how serious is this
it's serious in that it's not going to
be really
fixable you know he is
last year the surgery he had was to get
him back to where he was
in august and early september because it
worsened during the year
so he's going to enter the season karen
regent from the boston herald reporting
that it's unlikely he'll play it
the full season and i think that most of
us would have taken the under on julian
edelman
at 16 games anyway but there will be a
point where
he says yeah okay i can definitely get
open within 10 yards of the line of
scrimmage but can i do anything to make
people miss afterwards
can i protect myself um it'll be
interesting to see because i think the
nfl is going to have to be pride from
his
cold dead nfl hand um
before he gives up and i also think that
he is more
loyal to the patriots than other people
who
would get sideways with bill and say i
want to go someplace else so
i would be surprised if he doesn't
retire a patriot yeah but i also don't
think he's going to make a decision
before august
before i let you go we were talking
about this during the commercial break
who's the most
beloved sports star in boston
or new england history history yeah
i would say great kite okay that's
that's
that's what i went with uh i don't know
if i said bird or brady just those two
who's more beloved
i think bird probably and or bobby
is probably the most beloved because
it's just it is there's a
an aura around him but all of those guys
it
and yeah probably brady because there's
a lot of excuse me probably bird right
now because there's a lot of agitation
about brady's departure
and the success that he's had um byrne
is pretty much bulletproof
russell i think is adored for what he
did
and what he represents now i don't think
he was so adored in the 70s and 80s
but yeah we're free and lucky i mean
when you compare boston to the other
towns
maybe that's a good grab-ass story for
me on a friday
who's got the best array of
mount rushmore athletes who who dan who
well we're going to start brady's going
to be up there bird's going to be up
there
is bird over bill russell yeah i think
so
and then you know you got war
now you and your baseball player is you
got ted williams or or
or poppy so it's it's a tough array i
mean you put that up against colorado
you got john
elway and andre scalaraga or todd
okay but does southern california how do
you do los
angeles here well
well i mean who are you going to go with
in southern california i mean
well basketball i got a i got a variety
of
of guys to pick from kareem nobody likes
kareem
magic all right magic
um all right kobe's probably
stu but you're gonna have to go multiple
same sports yeah you're going to go with
for the kings
gretzky oh part-timer
but he still that was a huge moment when
he got traded from edmonton it changed
the nhl
all right so baseball i got sandy koufax
how's that that's good yeah
that's really good now football
ferragavo roman gabriel
eric dickerson i guess yeah i could have
i could have eric in there
i don't know if you're going to be able
to find a better mount rush more than
boston's
what about new york well about it
oh my god
hold on home slice i got joe namath and
i got babe ruth
to start out with okay
that's you name it he threw more pics
and touchdowns man
okay lawrence taylor okay that's better
okay
so uh
old frasier brady little frasier
that's i mean not larry bird
okay i mean you can you can try and
appropriate doc
from being in new jersey
all right maybe it's boston okay it is
black but why are you so defensive i'm
just it's this
it's a conversation
i got your pro creole right here
[Laughter]
help fritzy please not to do this to me
again
everybody is laughing at you
everybody ridiculous and you didn't buy
that for this appearance you owned that
well i had to fish it out but
did anybody ever tell you you look like
the uh the actor
uh charles uh from midnight run with de
niro
charles grodin no i have a very
malleable face i've gotten uh
i i've gotten the ed burns guy uh
i've gotten drew breezed i've been uh
i've been
messi'd um i've gotten uh
al bundy i could see
i could see uh charles grodin midnight
run with dinero
it was a great great performance yes it
was it's an unbelievable
i can see drew brees there i see a
little bit of that like drew brees with
a really ugly shirt on i could see it
yeah yeah you know what dan i said about
you all right tom
thanks for joining us i'll see you guys
talk to you soon that's tom
e curran tom eaker the uh patriots
insider